countries around the world start easing
coronavirus lockdowns raising concerns
among health experts US farmers are
forced to destroy their harvest as the
pandemic disrupts supply chains
Britain's Prime Minister goes back to
work and faces tough policy decisions
after recovering from kovat 19 I'm
Shelby Holliday and here's what you need
to know today the number of confirmed
coronavirus cases worldwide is about
three million with over 200,000 deaths
about 1 million infections have been
confirmed in the US but the number of
new cases in New York is waning US
states including Georgia South Carolina
and Texas started allowing some
non-essential businesses to reopen as
long as they follow guidelines health
researchers say the move comes weeks
before it's likely safe for these states
to reopen in Spain children went out for
the first time after six weeks under
lockdown and Italy plans to start
reopening from May 4th some developing
countries that have reported a
relatively low number of cases including
India and Ghana are also easing
lockdowns
but health specialists warned that cases
could surge as some shops and factories
open American farmers are having to dump
milk plow vegetables into the soil and
leave fruit to rot in the fields
that's because of lagging demand as
businesses are shut and aren't buying
products fruits and vegetables are
perishable and can't be stored making
suppliers particularly vulnerable
farmers are expecting to receive
financial support as part of a 19
billion dollar government aid package I
refuse to throw away all the effort and
the sacrifice of the British people and
to risk a second major outbreak Boris
Johnson the first head of government
known to have been infected with kovat
19 returned to 10 Downing Street after
spending two weeks recovering at his
country residence in his first public
appearance since being admitted to
intensive care in early April he urged
people not to lose patient
with the lockdown measures in his
absence the government has struggled to
work out a policy to loosen restrictions
as the death toll from the corona virus
continues to mount